pour visiter la Grèce un caducé n'est
pas
nécessaire mais il faut avoir
naturellement des ailes au pied des
ailes pour traverser les siècles qui
parfois sont fort longs pour faire le
tour de la pensée qui s'est enfermé ici
quelques temps pour réfléchir sur sa
nature et son
destin des ailes pour survoler le
parténon et le voir comme Zeus lui-même
le voyait sans toiture ni
secret pour se glisser à hauteur
d'architrave entre le temple de la
Victoire aPTARE et les jeunes filles
solidifiées de
l'érectillon en étudiant la leçon
définitive de ces blocs de marbre dont
l'agancement d'une perfection sans égal
nous a donner la définition d'ailleurs
incompréhensible de ce que nous appelons
depuis la beauté
il faut des ailes pour passer par-dessus
le bois sacré sans C tarder à musarder
avec les mususe qui pour le moment
semble d'ailleurs avoir peu de chose à
dire au
siècles
et pour descendre doucement sur delelfph
où règne le souvenir du temple d'Apollon
au fronton duquel on pouvait lire le
fameux connais-toi toi-même devinette
socratique à laquelle chacun répond ce
qui lui
plaît ce que vous allez voir durant ce
voyage aérien je vais vous le dire sans
plus attendre je me charge de la route
regardez le
paysage vous allez
voir des rochers et Fleuré par les
personnages de légende qui sont au
commencement de
l'histoire des pierres sous chacune
desquel il y a un dieu
mort des monastères Byzantins perchés
dans le silence des hauteurs et que l'on
désigne sous le nom de Météor vous
verrez le Piré que Joseph prudom prenait
pour un homme et qui est en réalité un
enfant vous verrez miconos son port ses
armes son pélican d'une longue escale
ses pêcheurs à la ligne ses ruelles
ensoleillé ses moulins en sommeill aux
élitre flasque et d'un bon vous serez à
dos heureux voltigeur vous admirerez ses
lions qui ressemble à des Panthères un
bas relief où vous croirez peut-être
reconnaître en passant deux personnages
de La Marseillaise de
Rude on vous Cera
les mosquées de ce pays où les religions
viennent l'une après l'autre tenir
conférence avec la
raison on vous montrera la crête et ces
danseuses de folklore libéré de leur
fris antique par un air de guitare
etnosos le palais de Minos et ses
archives de pierre et vous apercevrez
rod sa forteresse ses palais ses
fontaines son des chevaliers de
Saint-Jean
l'Hospitalier
Olympie siège de l'une des SEP
merveilles du monde la plus grande de
toutes étant évidemment qu'un si petit
peuple en est instruit de si grand
depuis si longtemps sur tous les bancs
de toutes les écoles du
monde
vous verrez des stades des théâtres en
éventail épidor et Corin
vous aurez vu la Grèce enfin ces harpes
de colonne doré le seul pays peut-être
avec la France à bénéficier d'une sorte
de passeport sentimental dans la vie
intérieure des nations les plus
lointaines la graisse blanche et bleu
comme son drapeau détruite et
indestructible qui nous envoie du fond
des âges sa lumière d'étoil disparu et
je vous laisse partir et je me tais
barbare que je
suis
j'avais promis de me taire de ne pas
troubler votre silence intérieur par des
interventions
intempestive bref de ne pas mettre les
pieds dans vos
images mais comment command pas répondre
par un dernier hommage au discours de
ces pierres qui depuis des millénaires
disent au ciel et au vent ce que peut
l'être humain quand par miracle ou par
hasard ou par grâce confidentielle il a
trouvé la clé la mesure et l'accord
parfait de l'art et de la nature qui
chante
encore